i had an interesting experience recently
that i'd like to share yep sony you know
this about me i tend to lose my kindles
i shed kindles
i don't know what it is it's something
about the size of a kindle i don't
usually i don't think lose things
but this
i know glasses i lose glasses sunglasses
and glasses but phone yeah didn't you
drive off with your phone on the roof or
something lost your wallet my phone yeah
my wallet yeah i lost a son
sean if you're out there
yeah i do love you um and i wish i had
made some attempt to find you but anyway
okay i do lose things and but one of the
things i lose regularly is a kindle i'll
get a kindle and i love the kindle
because i travel a lot uh especially uh
in non-coveted times i travel all the
time and i love to read i love not
hauling around a lot of books
so i had a kindle lost it had another
kindle
lost it got another candle lost it
now i know so i go out and i buy
my fourth
kindle uh because i'm gonna take my wife
and children on a vacation i buy the
kindle and you know you have to set it
up so i put in all my information and i
set it up and it says great you know
welcome back and i see that there's the
home screen and then it says library
which tells you about all the books that
you bought so i think i wonder if
there's any books in there that i bought
that i forgot to read it's been a while
since i had my kindle since i lost it so
i go into library and i see
oh there's a book i bought on teddy
roosevelt oh there's another book i
bought on teddy roosevelt there's a book
i bought on
world war ii and another book i bought
on world war ii yeah and then i see
this
tom clancy
spy novel i'm like huh
i never buy those
then i see another one then i see
all these different
spy
novels oh i'm listening uh who else was
in there james patterson james patterson
like people have i never read this stuff
and i'm seeing more and more than tons
of them
then i start to see all these books
on how to drive
how to drive a car
and i'm like like definitely didn't buy
that and then it's like how to drive
a stick shift like a boss yep how to
drive a truck how to drive this how to
drive that i'm like i don't i didn't
find these books then i start to see
how to talk to ladies with confidence
and then i start to see then you know
you're back in your own book yeah that i
knew oh good now
now that i bought then i start to see
there's uh
i have some
read them right okay okay so there's one
of the books is the manual to manhood
how to cook the perfect steak change the
tire and press and then it goes on
and then there's another one forbidden
and explicit erotica for adults yes yeah
then there's another one which is
the
seven percent man a pickup strategy yes
which i think i've heard about which is
some strategy where
if you
hit 100 women seven will at least say
yes you know or or at least they'll talk
to you for more than a second about
quantity it's about quantity of times
that you and i'm reading and then it
gets into mixed martial arts yep and
then there's stuff like using the power
of the mind to unlock and and i'm i call
you up and i go what is this and you
said
was your kindle locked and i said no i
didn't know you could lock a kindle
which i didn't i didn't know you could
lock a kindle that you could put a lock
in i never got that far i'm not a you
know and she was like yeah
a very horny 16 year old boy
has your kindle and is buying books like
crazy and i was like of course because
it's all
spy thrillers i need to learn how to
drive how do i pick up a 35 year old yes
sexy girl
i want to do sex
i need to use my mind power to control
everyone around me there's crypto stuff
in there yeah crypto stuff and so anyway
i put a code on my kindle but the
problem now and we got rid of all those
books yeah the problem though is the
amazon keep suggesting
so i keep opening up my kindle and it
will say have you thought about you know
you know
have you thought about how to how to get
a 44 year old milf
in the sack
seven techniques that work
half the time every time yeah
and it was so easy to clean your library
because i was like oh is this about a
war or a president and that's conan's
anything else was like sex mma driving
but the thing is is that for the rest of
my life kendall's going to be saying oh
who is this so conan hey conan we know
what you'd like
15 ways to
talk your way into a ladies room
this similar thing happened to me
because amanda and i share
a kindle account and so it takes our
interests and blends them together so
yeah kind of pulpy spy novels like this
kid and she reads a lot of like
maternity books and so we get these like
female romance novels like
bad jonah and president sex oh guess
what i would love it if they blended
mine because if they blended the kids
and mine it would be like how to talk
sexy to theodore roosevelt
[Laughter]
trying to get abraham lincoln in the
sack
and then knock him out with a special
taekwondo kick
please do that please please blend my
accounts
oh wow okay that was fun anyway um
i you know i did cancel that one account
so i'm sorry kid
you're out there and you're listening to
this um but you you did get like 60
books i did treat you to 60 books so
yeah my hope is that little
whoever kevin shows up your door with a
35 year old woman he needs to drive in a
ferrari
thanks cones cones thanks to you i i met
erica here
i've got a maserati
and now if you excuse me and then he
sweeps his leg around and knocks me
unconscious
i love that all right onward and upward